Speaker 1: I am repulsed today.
Truly repulsed by having to do this story,
but we are seeing a massive covid resurgence
right now, which is leading to some countries
in stating health passes, new vaccine requirements,
speculative third vaccine doses and much,
much more.
And it's all because we aren't vaccinating
enough people in some parts of the world because
they don't yet have vaccines in the United
States, because we have so many ignorant anti
vaccines here in the United States.
Daily cases are now up.
Listen to this.
Sixty nine percent.
Sixty nine percent cases up in the United
States.
Globally, cases are now up twenty four percent.
What is happening?
The Delta variant, combined with not enough
vaccination, the Delta variant is about 60
percent more contagious than the original
variant.
It's spreading, yes, mostly among unvaccinated
people.
That is a testament to the effectiveness of
the vaccines.
But it's not exclusively among the unvaccinated
because the vaccines aren't 100 percent effective
and the vaccines were not designed specifically
to be tailored to the Delta variant.
And right now, as many people in the United
States continue to refuse to get vaccinated,
things are increasingly pointed to a very
ugly fall of twenty, twenty one.
I am fully expecting at this point, you know,
three months ago I said in the fall, as we
get into flu season, I would be fine with
saying, hey, we've got to go back to masks
at the grocery store and stuff like that.
At this point, I'm fully expecting that masks
are coming back on in the fall in a widespread
manner unless people really go out and get
vaccinated right now.
Now, as a result, look at what's going on
around the world.
Remember, much of the world doesn't yet have
access to vaccines like we have in the US.
In France, the president, Emmanuel Macron,
is putting in place new health rules, including
the EU digital covid certificate.
Some people call this the health pass and
it's going to be mandatory.
If you want to go to any cultural venue, if
you want to go to the movies, you will have
to be using the health pass.
Starting in August, the health pass will be
mandatory to go to cafes, shops and restaurants,
as well as trains and planes, among other
places.
France is also going to require health care
workers be vaccinated if they want to continue
working around patients and in health care
settings.
In Israel, one of the most vaccinated countries
in the world, they are now starting third
doses of the Pfizer vaccine for the most at
risk adults.
Why?
It's relatively speculative.
There's the idea that a third dose might provide
more protection, particularly for at risk
folks.
It is not something that the House says is
indicated.
The show says, let's keep giving first doses
to completely unvaccinated people.
But desperation is growing as even Israel
is seeing, OK, it's a very little increase
in cases.
Israel is so highly vaccinated that it's not
a big increase.
But there are more breakthrough cases happening
in Israel as well as Delta variant cases among
people who have not been vaccinated.
Tennessee has now fired its top vaccine official
because covid-19 is showing signs of massive
spread in Tennessee.
California cases are now up one hundred and
eighty one percent compared to the previous
week.
So is there any good news?
The good news continues to be we have a tool
that works really well against the Delta variant
if we all use it.
And when a vaccinated person does get infected,
they are overwhelmingly, completely asymptomatic.
Most Breakthru vaccinated infections are asymptomatic,
not all, and there are vaccinated people who
have died.
I understand that now in the US, officials
are saying almost all recent hospitalizations
and deaths are unvaccinated people.
And that's true, but not all.
And this is a community effort.
This is a joint effort here.
There are countries that, as they get access
to the vaccine, are already seeing way more
interest in getting it than we've seen in
the United States.
Look at Canada, for example.
Canada got significant vaccine access much
later than the United States, and yet they're
quickly catching up to the US in terms of
per capita second doses.
So we need to deal with anti vaccines somehow.
And there are real concerns about what things
look like in the fall.
If we don't do that, just look at the numbers.
These are not vague.
You know, it's so easy to hear these headlines.
Oh, it's more contagious.
Oh, some people don't want to get and have
some total disconnect from the fact that this
means people develop symptoms that get so
bad that they go to the hospital and some
of them never come out.
And it can mostly be avoided just by going
and getting vaccinated.
So the fall I understand that this is becoming
overwhelmingly a pandemic of the unvaccinated,
but not completely.
And it's not.
Simple as well, if you don't want to get vaccinated,
you're the only one at risk that is not the
case.
All right.
So as we head into the fall, we're going to
continue watching this.
By the way, also, as we head into the fall,
The David Pakman Show will be hitting our
16 year anniversary.
Our 16th anniversary, I believe, is the right
way to say it.
And in fact, on August 16th, we will be doing
a one day, 16 year membership blowout.
I would love for you to join the ranks of
membership to celebrate our 16th year and
really the start of the 17th year.
Right.
OK, and you can be notified of that on August
16th just by getting on our membership on
our newsletter.
You can sign up for it at David Pakman Dotcom
and let me know your thoughts about where
you see the pandemic going in the fall by
sending me a message on Twitter at David Pakman.
Our show is primarily dependent on support
from folks like you, if you listen to the
show, if you watch the show and you like it
enough, you don't have to like it that much.
But if you like it enough that you want it
to continue.
Grab yourself a membership at Join Pakman
dot com.
We do a daily extra show, the bonus show,
world famous and award winning bonus show
every single day for our members.
And we have all sorts of other great member
benefits, including a commercial free audio
feed of the show every day, a commercial free
video feed of the show every day and more
sign up at Join Pakman Dotcom.
Take a discount if you want the coupon code
better.
Twenty one saving you a pretty penny as the
kids say these days